[Music]
this gamma-ray burst is the last thing
that mankind will see before we are
blown out of existence we are
essentially staring down the barrel of a
gun I know about your work I know they
turn them back on
but what if I told you I had a plan it's
the only thing powerful enough to stop
what's coming I need you to lift that
firearm you shoot this woman in the head
or I'm gonna put a bullet in your
daughter's head it's time to see what
you're made of I shut down the program
15 minutes to get to the next location
clock's ticking show me how strong you
really are when the universe decides
what it wants it's pointless to resist
with the police in hot pursuit we are
now being told the man's name is Joseph
Steadman what the streets closed down
now
did you do to me now you see how this
works Joe the angrier you get the more
you unlocked Oh see how far we can put
its time you to dig deeper Joe we need
to unlock
I've really never seen anything like
this
[Music]
there are powers out there that are
greater than us
you